I do want to add quickly though that  that fallacy is that's a fallacy and I  see this a lot in the black community  where you know a lot of the time  black women and a lot of black community  know up the pain points and  communication and there's always a  defensive kind of like oh it's  self-editing you know if if I kind of  calm myself down and understand this  that it's me not loving myself and  there's all this pushback and you  realize feminine women don't really do  that like feminine women like watch  their calm they're very careful with  their tone you know they fit into every  conversation and I think that's  something as a community we need to we  need to promote that those kind of  values like you can be a classy black  woman who's not loud who's kind of you  know Suave about how you engage yourself  it's not it doesn't mean you're not you  don't love yourself